yeah all right so let's talk about this
you had uh Andrew Tate on your um show
about 72 hours before he was arrested
somewhere in that area was it I don't
think it was that it was it you were it
was in December it was pretty close he
was arrested on December 3 30th and you
had him on pretty close to that oh yeah
well it was like the maybe like the 10th
or something oh so oh man no yeah we
dropped the video we had like a whole
commercial for it so we dropped it like
super okay because that's why I was
confused yeah yeah yeah
um in that whole instance what did you
think about having mon what did you
think about the reaction what do you
think about that whole the whole thing I
thought that panel was genius I think
that was the best panel I ever put
together
um I I'm just like who would have
thought put Brittany Renner on a panel
with Andrew Tay I thought of it you know
um because whenever I put together a
panel I'm always trying to put two
people on like opposite ends yeah I
wanted Amber Rose imagine if I got Amber
Rose but I didn't think of it but um
well she her fee was like 30k I'm like I
don't want you that bad the problem
problem with Andrew Rose Amber Rose as
opposed to Brittany Renner is Amber Rose
is not out there trying Andrew Rose is
just openly saying I have sex with men
whenever I want and I'm not ashamed of
it right yeah but she's not trying to
benefit human beings Brittany Renner at
the end of your interview said one of
the most appalling things I've ever
[__] heard anyone say she goes I
believe that my voice is necessary in
this space and I'm like [__] how
there's videos of you saying you [__]
three guys in one day and your vagina
hurts how and you don't even denounce
those videos please explain to me why
I've not seen that one yes yeah dude
it's really bad like look at the ones
like when she was in college I know I've
seen some but I I see the three guys oh
god well she's like talking oh my vagina
hurts because I have [__] three days
one day and I'm like my whole thing is
like you're telling me now that your
voice needs to be hurt I don't I agree
you are you have a right to an opinion I
love uh quantum mechanics but there's
already guys doing podcasts on that my
voice is not necessary in that space
yeah does that make sense like there's
already guys doing NBA podcasts my voice
is not necessary are in the space the
idea that for male or female
self-improvement your voice is necessary
in the space like how dare you that [__]
was crazy to me like what you could do
is say hey I made some mistakes yeah
because I made the mistakes here's what
I can do to help you get moved forward
she's not even doing that though she's
not even like saying she [__] up
before she's saying I [__] up now how
do we fix the world to accept what I did
bro what you did to PJ Washington was
[__] terrible and you deserve the
chat like hey you want to go to [__]
Charlotte Bobcats game with me because I
bet you aren't going to be allowed to go
in like what happened there is like so
bad and she doesn't accept the
responsibility for what she did that's
the difference that's why I think
Brittany Renner was a better guest than
Amber Rose you see what I'm saying yeah
because Brittany Renner is going to try
to cope which makes for better content
right Amber Rose is not going to try to
coat Amber Rose is going to be like I'm
a hoe thank you go for it appreciate my
wholeness I'm for everybody they find us
at every party I'm saying ain't gonna be
loyal not for anybody yeah that's a
different
her fee was crazy I was like yeah I
can't do that but but yeah so we had um
Brittany Renner
um then two guests from the show
um on on and Andrew was really I mean
people always ask me what he was like
but he was so quick in and out like he
was working on like a time crunch so it
was like he walked through the door we
sat him down we started filming and then
he left so but he was super nice um I
was supposed to go to Dubai actually for
it and I actually I lost like 15 000
because my old assistant didn't get trip
insurance I don't think no it's like
kill myself
um so it was don't clip that but I went
but yeah we were all supposed to go to
Dubai and film it and then my passport
expired within six months I didn't know
they wouldn't let me in the country I'm
American I'm spoiled I'm like what they
won't let me in but I'm American I'm
like what I've never dealt with this
before yeah I thought I could get into
anywhere yet not the case so we had to
cancel that whole trip and then he ended
up coming which was like really nice
yeah so yeah
enjoyed how it seemed like his tone and
tenor made the the even the people who
didn't like him they started listening
to him more it's almost like they felt
like the whole panel was kind of on his
side there by the end of it yeah I mean
I even learned things from him during
that panel because he like the way he
explained like just uh I can't remember
what it was now but just certain things
from like the point of view of a guy I
was like I've never thought about like
how to get the guy to stop playing video
games and he was like why don't you guys
say it like this I was like yeah I
should yeah I should it was yeah yeah
one of my favorite analogies that he
uses is that like when like the amount
of work that I did to buy this yacht
compared to be on this yacht versus the
amount of work that those models in
Monaco did to be on this yacht when you
were in your early 20s you were not
interested in monogamy but now I'm being
judged in my mid-40s for not being
interested in monogamy yeah that's what
I that's what's interesting um like
women like we pick non-monogamy yeah
yeah that yeah that was one of the
topics is like when I if you were to
talk to Mia Khalifa or Lana Rose in
their early 20s and said are you
interested in monogamy now they'd be
like no and then if you said do you
think that older men should be willing
to date you even though you're in early
20s I guarantee you they would have said
yes yeah then later on when all sudden
they're not in that age bracket anymore
now Mia Khalifa says well there's
something wrong with men who want to
date younger women and I'm like no
you're just not a younger woman anymore
yeah you weren't interested you were
very much interested in older men when
you were younger and by the way maybe
she wasn't maybe she's the exception
most women in their early 20s if you ask
them would you date a handsome what like
uh 38 year old man who's doing well and
is financially secure they would be like
yes you know what's interesting oh my
gosh I really did not look at guys that
much older than me when I was my like 21
22. my mom was like don't don't date
guys too old that's like the funny thing
yeah because you the whole thing like
you have kids and then they'll be
geriatric or something like that no no
like when I was like 21 or 22 like when
or in college my mom was like don't date
like like guys that are too much like in
their 30s or anything which is
interesting because I don't know if that
was good advice or not my girlfriend
didn't realize I was over 40 when we met
and I didn't realize that she was under
21 when we met oh my she's under 21. oh
she's 21 now oh wow I'm 24 years older
than her yeah oh wow I have no idea and
if you hang out with her she seems so
much more mature no I'm surprised I
thought she was like mid late 20s yeah
yeah it's crazy oh um I mean she's
beautiful though yeah she's she's
awesome yeah she's so cool I I picked
her because she'd be down to kill
somebody for me and I don't want her to
kill anybody for me but like if somebody
was like jumping on my back she's down
to do whatever like this the Loyalty
does that make sense how did you meet
her I was hosting swimsuit USA's World
Championship I'm one of the hosts for
that oh that's awesome and she was a
finalist for that she'd done like
multiple pageants maybe 20 30 pageants
before that and then she did swimsuit
USA's world championship and then I met
her there and we just hit it off and at
first she didn't take it seriously and I
was like no this you're the girl I want
for sure 100 and then I flew her out and
then she moved in a couple months later
and she's been with me for the last uh
since October 27th oh wow yep that's
pretty much how it's worked
um so she was so cool I just I liked her
and whatever yeah I was a fan when she
was talking to the like only fans chicks
or whatever I was like you tell them
yeah it was interesting like yeah the
thing is here's the thing people were
offended by that clip but in the
beginning of the clip she literally says
you can do only fans if you want yeah no
one it's like they don't they don't
commute or compute like even if I say
I'm not talking about you yeah I'm not
talking about you personally then
they're like but I and I'm like isn't it
crazy it's like the qualifier is there
and you're still offended yeah that's to
me it's like you're not arguing in good
faith at that point right let's have a
that's why the thing with me and Destiny
went so well is because Destiny kept
bringing up evolutionary psychology
studies that's my specialty so I loved
that debate he didn't call me [__]
names now he said I was a Coke had on
one of his live streams he doesn't know
me I've never tried Coke in my life I
get it but like when we met in person
there was no ad hominem attacks I
appreciate that do that but what happens
is you have these discussions with
people and you just use just just a a
squirt of consequences just this might
happen to you yeah you [__]
misogynist and it's like it hurts more
here's the other thing I found when I
say it's my opinion it hurts when I can
show studies that hurts so much more
well and it's like what outcomes does
this lead to and like that's what that's
what I'm always saying like what what
outcomes does this craziness lead to for
women like why I just don't like liars
and I just hate it and I hate it when
Sims do this too they act like there's
no consequences for women when they and
it irritates me more because I'm like
you guys know you know deep down why are
they doing that though because they're
trying to get laid yes yes they know
again like the anthem go everybody go
listen to Juicy J they for everybody
they're for everybody yeah but but you
know what I love about that song he goes
they for everybody but I still love
these hoes he knows they go in this
category yeah right it's an extreme
example no yeah but but Juicy J saying
the the they for everybody you they're
not gonna be loyal for anybody yeah but
I love these hoes he keeps them over
here they're not his wife
they're for everybody but he understands
that and so that's the difference for me
is like I do whatever you want to do I'm
going to explain to you some
consequences I'm going to show you some
math about these consequences it's going
to be harder for you to stay in a
relationship if you've had sex with 50
men your just your neurology is
different when you have sex with 50 men
forget about the morality of it go ahead
yeah well I think of it like alcohol
like if you drink alcohol every day
you're not gonna get as drunk when you
drink it if you have sex with every like
a new guy every single day you're not
going to follow us in love when you do
it yeah Myron was he likes to use
adhesive tape it's like every time I
pull the tape off yeah it sticks left oh
they use that in Cal you got that from
Catholic School Purity things that's
what they would they would I I we had
Chastity speakers every year yes okay if
you want to do that that's fine but the
other thing that's crazy to me is when
women brag to me they're like oh I can
have sex without feelings I'm like don't
brag about it just like ladies just be
quiet like you just pull out your dick
at that point you're that's a masculine
trait why are you bragging about a
masculine trait does that do you
understand yeah and when you tell me
that you know what that makes me think
okay cool you'd be fun you're e for
everybody let me you know for
recreational use only I'll have sex with
you and then I'll just move on because
you just said you can do it without
feelings that actually makes me less
likely to want to be with you because I
know I can have sex with you you're not
going to trip about it but here's the
thing they still trip about it they
still trip about like the girl who says
I don't catch any feelings when she Mets
the guy who absolutely doesn't catch any
feelings for her then she catches
feelings
well what well and it's crazy I asked
the girl on the show that slept with 200
guys how many how many did you actually
like love or like were you like did you
actually really like guess how many she
said out of 200 guess I want to see a
few
I need to ask you a question if this is
the girl real quick out of
uh she probably four
you're close five that's what she said
um
I was like how do you find 200 people
you I don't even know 200 people
oh my God I have to know if this is the
girl because I didn't she just wrote me
there's a girl that said she slept with
a hundred on my show too and she said
around five too okay can we talk about
that so she got mad because she said her
body count and then she called you out
for it which which one was the girl
with the 200 no okay no my mom's about
to hit her up and be like she was the
girl sitting right across from you she
was outside oh I remember she was cool
she was cool yeah
um so you said you had a girl come on
your show and you you said do body
counts matter and just to prove the
point girls do not say what their body
count is yeah and then you said do you
want to say your body count and the girl
set her body count and then later on had
tried to sue you because you posted it
raised like 10 thousand dollars to sue
me pounds I'm like you guys are her
objective was to get that pulled off no
okay so this was fairly early this was
super early when I first started the
show so this is like like the audio was
so bad this episode anyway
um but yeah so it was an episode on body
count and I was like all right guys to
start the show what's your body count
hahaha I say never mind you don't have
to say it and there's a guy there and a
girl with three of us and the guy was
like yeah cool I'm not you know and the
girl was like oh I'll say it I'm like
are you sure she says she's sure I'm
here for the content yes see here's the
microphone and she said now get him on
these whatever shows this sounds low
compared to these girls but she was like
like 30 or something and I was like whoa
that's wild and she um so whatever she's
body positive we have a whole
conversation about this yeah at the end
of the show I say would you come back
she says yes okay and also in the
beginning of the show so lady if you're
watching this just so you know I have
texts of you confirming what podcast you
were coming on and knowing where you
were going so stop with this I didn't
know [__] I have text to prove this
lady that raised ten thousand dollars to
sue me she's keeping that money you
idiot all the guy people that gave her
money she's just keeping it like stupid
sorry I just need to get that out there
but but um she freaking
um yeah and then she just wanted me to
take the stream down and I just think
like I put so much work to put on these
shows I can't pull it you can blur out
words after the fact in it's in YouTube
Studio pretty sure you can
if that's a big an issue I think I would
do that no it takes a while because it
has to re-render the entire video yeah
I've done it before yeah but it was for
copyrighted music I cut some of it out
in the middle of the video but like that
that is no like I'm not no I'm gonna say
do it outside that's impossible instead
of taking it down yeah no well my thing
is no I pay I pay money to put this on
we tell you before it's live and she
knew it was live so it's like if you
want to say it this is not like you're a
grown adult and men have said things and
gotten roasted for it and they don't do
like have the same reaction but women do
yeah um but yeah so then she said she
was gonna sue me and that she was like
autistic and that she couldn't consent
and like I was like so we're taking as
many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible